a
[Laughter]
sassy plus everything hello we are P1
Harmony and we're with BuzzFeed ready to
answer 30 questions as fast as possible
let's
[Music]
go scrambled eggs bacon bacon and potato
potato I had Tha food me and Feld had
instant
noodles wait who's
who
it's it's me okay show
your I'm
okay
[Music]
uh that was not very good what artist
are you over now gorill TLC what's your
name fire Emoji P1 fire emoji
I sent a video it was like a little
YouTube shorts thing and it was talking
about like goodlooking people and in was
in it so just sent it to
us I like skinny
jeans I said mayonnaise is the best
sauce in the world oh that is a hot
yeah she was like what's your
favorite
[Laughter]
I want to do something like greasy but
like it's like it's like that good
grease kind of like masculine and like
Macho I want to try to P Pang teenager
P I thought he
said is like The
Sassy everyone's type orp Libra andj
Libra inj
Scorpio Aquarius
Aquarius wait I'm assigning them that
was what my sister said like cuz we have
three we have three so my sister is
courney and I'm Kim and my brother's
Chloe I think CH is Courtney Theo is
Chloe chab is also Chloe no CH is Kylie
in is Kendall wow soul is soul is Chris
I'm very Hands-On so I love to show my
affection but I don't like when people
touch me so it's like I like to touch
people I don't like people touch me I
just I'm just saying words of
affirmation I think I don't usually say
or express my
feeling
oh I'm
lovely fapr one two
three red flag oh chewing sound I think
too much
reaction for me I think it's people that
don't know how to be serious I say don't
touch
[Laughter]
don't performance director director
director what's your favorite M the meme
that that that Kio changes to the fish
yeah that's my
favorite all time favorite oh no no my
favorite
[Laughter]
is
okay okay what is your
favorite my life is pretty fun I pick K
I pick the my life is pretty fun
[Laughter]
one two three jump one two three
jump you have to hold your
breath
jump
e
jump okay wait a minute makes a pose he
always I say Justin
[Laughter]
Bieber you
oh cat dog hamster ah chameleon hamster
hamster
wolf horse or fish and he is llama yes
we'll do
that P1 P buz
buz
Harmony I believe we got one right here
W incredible there are aliens in space
but we can't meet them it's it's it's
hard the timing right the reason we
can't meet Aliens cuz it's hard guys
hard po yogurt ice yogurt ice cream
chicken yes Pizza what show are you
watching right now oh I'm watching
Modern Family I'm watching Ida if you
could collab with
we just collabed with tricky which is
amazing I kind of want to collab with
another band you know I say gorillas
yeah like
gorillas that was
good yeah oh this was a challenge thank
you so much buzzby for having
us we have a new song called fall Love
Again produced by Trick and belief so
please take a look at for that hopefully
we'll be back very soon on BuzzFeed
thank you guys so much this has been P1
Harmony thank
[Music]
you